peter du hat es ja auch die gelegenheit
mit dem sprecher der berliner polizei zu
sprechen und genau in diesem beitrag
wollen wir jetzt einmal reinschauen
die letzte zählung was die anzahl
betrifft schon eine ganze weile her an
die mir jetzt vorliegt aber wir haben
uns da den 20.000 genährt wir sind ja
ein teil einer nicht ganz so positive
bilanz weil wir letzten endes die
versammlung auflösen mussten den aufzug
auflösen mussten es kamen wir dazu dass
massiv gegen die auflagen die auch das
oberverwaltungsgericht ja erlassen hat
verstoßen wurde also der mindestabstand
wurde nicht eingehalten
schutzvorkehrungen wurden nicht beachtet
so dass wir letzten endes nach dem
abgestuften vorgehen mit den menschen
sprechen lautsprecherdurchsagen und ich
habe sogar noch mal versucht wird den
mund nasenschutz eine lösung zu finden
letzten endes dann doch auflösen mussten
jetzt wird aber richtung siegessäule
gezogen wie wollen sie garantieren dass
eben auch die hygiene abstände da
eingehalten werden beziehungsweise mund
nasen schutz getragen wird
wir gehen einer siegessäule also auf der
straße des 17 juni und rund um die
siegessäule natürlich identisch vor das
heißt wir werden auch dort wieder mit
den menschen sprechen die dann auch dort
wieder darauf hinweisen die
mindestabstände einzuhalten was wir
nicht ersetzen können das haben das
verantwortungsbewusstsein das
verantwortliche handeln einer jeden
einzelnen eines jeden einzelnen
wir brauchen aber natürlich auf die
vernunft wieder hoffen auf die vernunft
und wenn nicht werden die ähnlich
vorgehen müssen
und dem 22 auflösen müssen können sie
noch was zu den zwischenfällen sagen es
kam einst vereinzelt zu rangeleien
absperrung wollen durch brauchen wir
haben bereich friedrichstraße unter den
linden kam es auch zu flaschenwürfen auf
einsatzkräfte wohnen dort angegangen
wurden dort angegriffen sodass wir
vereinzelt festnahmen durchführen
mussten wir hoffen dass das tatsächlich
das einzige war was jetzt kurz auf
kochte was sich emotional entlud dort
und hoffen wir einfach darauf dass der
tat weiterhin friedlich verläuft
wie wollen sie jetzt heute abend weiter
verfahren weiter mit dieser
deeskalationsstrategie wir bleiben
grundsätzlich bei diesem konzept
natürlich das heißt wir sprechen mit den
menschen wir werden dieses abgestufte
verfahren weiter fortsetzen es geht ja
eben darum verhältnismässig vorzugehen
und
sie müssen wir auch entsprechend
dokumentieren das versuchen wir dann
genauso und identischen maße jetzt gab
es eine information oder auch dass die
beamten nicht diese fnp zwei oder drei
masken haben gab es da irgendwie vorrats
probleme oder dergleichen
die atemschutzmasken die ffb zwei masken
zum beispiel die haben wir in
ausreichender anzahl vorrätig das ist
gar nicht das problem aber eben im
zusammenhang mit der polizeilichen
tätigkeit das ist nicht immer möglichen
mund nasenschutz zu tragen es geht auch
um gewisse aspekte der eigensicherung
wenn sie so eine maske aufgesetzt haben
sehen sie auch manchmal nicht was im
unteren bereich passiert das kann
durchaus gerade in situationen wie
eskalieren sehr gefährlich sein
das heißt jede einsatzkraft ist
natürlich grundsätzlich angehalten sich
zu schützen das zählt auch darunter
aber man muss halt auch immer eine
abwägung der jeweiligen situation
schauen dieses gerade oder nicht deshalb
sind wir auch entsprechend ausgenommen